[Music]
welcome back to off the record we're
talking about what
we want
gilbert's here michael's here
you were talking about ted bunny go go
yeah so we watched you
why did you decide to watch something so
sinister she's the one that wanted to
watch it oh really that's that kind of
stuff should she find him attractive
no she actually did it and i was like
you don't think this guy's attractive
she goes i like asian guys
i think she might were you judging her
like you shouldn't you shouldn't have a
fetish yeah i do give her [ __ ] about
that sometimes i ask her like do you
have asian guy i think her mom always
says she does but yeah she's not a weeb
so it's okay yeah that's right she also
you're the first boyfriend right yeah
baby yeah would you be more hurt if like
she was checking out dudes and she was
like
she thought
she was attracted to another asian dude
or another like latin dude which one
would you be more hurt by
options just with me
i think all three would hurt equally as
bad
oh actually first two hurt more last one
not that bad at least they're happy yeah
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it gives us a great smile so i'm
like yeah you know it's infectious when
this guy smiles i just go yeah
my wife's cheating on him yeah no big
deal dude it happens no we're watching
the ted bundy stuff and
uh
the whole case is crazy i had no idea
how
once he got arrested he was only accused
of killing two people but apparently he
is
like killed 30
30 to 40 people did he not get charged i
forgot which one is ted bundy he's the
handsome guy yeah the handsome charming
there's a lot of handsome killers
oh the one that already had a wife or a
girlfriend and she had no [ __ ] idea
that one that one's good and he's
supposed to be like really charming and
very like handsome was this on netflix
yeah
he looks creepy as [ __ ] to me but this
is also with the context of me
understanding that he's murdered maybe
hundreds of women definitely have
fangirls on twitter dude this guy
represented himself in court and it was
like all good that's right zac efron
played him right
this is ted bundy zach everyone played
him i forgot bro have you seen what zac
efron looks like
have you seen what he looks like
recently wait can i see the original um
or when he was bundy yeah because i
don't know anything about this story he
looks creepy as [ __ ] but he like
represent himself in court and he just
got away with a lot just because he was
kind of a smooth talker and the judge
kind of liked him a lot he's like man
it's a shame if you just got your life
together this wouldn't have happened wow
yeah like that's what he was saying to
him and i was thinking i was like yo if
he was any of the race you think he
would [ __ ] get away with that [ __ ]
back then no way yeah
yeah i think so
it's hard to resist a charming white man
yeah dude
i don't know i i'd like to argue that i
don't i don't even that's the peak of
charming as a charming white man i
honestly think like a smooth talking
like older asian dude this is ted bunny
it's pretty like
that's zach
he's a giant
the purpose of this bit the third time
he does it is zach keffer in high school
musical
i read that
[ __ ] you all right getting ahead of it
you can see my screen you would have
fooled me and i was thinking damn that
guy looks like a celebrity like an actor
yeah there you go
oh wow oh yeah yeah they do have a
resemblance yeah he played him in a
movie
yeah yeah yeah he's creepy dude he's
super creepy talkers can get you at a
lot of places in life yeah no and he
he's like the epitome of that like
because you watch him in the court they
have like actually that was like i guess
the first
murder trial that they filmed from the
beginning to the end
and you see him talking to everybody
everyone is like on the edge of their
seat listening to this guy talk
and he and he was i guess he wanted to
be a lawyer and he didn't represent
himself he's like finally here's my time
to shine but he finagled his way to like
representing himself because usually
that never happens i mean you're allowed
to i mean usually people don't want to
lose yeah they don't do it themselves
this guy's confident and he kind of
almost he almost kind of got away with
it like he was pretty close but really
smooth but the evidence was just
overwhelming he just channeled his
passion in just the wrong [ __ ]
killing women
if he only channeled it he was really
good at it
that's him
in court representing himself i would be
willing to make a general argument but
we reserve the right to submit to the
court a memorandum
of uh
so he kept firing lawyers
he kept getting a new lawyer he had he
had up to like four lawyers on his team
and he kept firing a couple here and
there and then he only was uh charged
for two murders
then he got the death penalty he goes
back to court again gets charged for
another murder gets double death penalty
and then right at the right when he was
about to get electrocuted on the chair
he starts confessing to all the 30 to 40
other women he killed
and then they're just like wait you
killed more yeah and they're always like
my credit now because he wanted to
because he wanted to extend
how much longer he would be able to oh
right so he was saying give me another
day and i'll tell you the 30 40 people
that i killed and there were like he
really do did he get the extra day yeah
they did they gave him an extra day and
then he kept telling like just expanding
on how many more people he just kept
lying so he could stay alive for another
day but it was because he was here mr
bunny we're at 85 people you exactly he
knew exactly where the bodies were oh
he told them that like he decapitated
half a dozen women or a dozen women and
he he told them exactly where
you know they were buried in this
mountain range and state to state he was
he went from california all the way to
florida
you know what's crazy is that uh they
tie him and his girlfriend arguing and
getting into these like
uh situations is what
got him to take out his anger on other
women outside
so every time they got into a fight or
things went bad he went out and and
killed a woman
wow and the whole time
his lover
had no [ __ ] idea these things were
happening because she saw him as this
like
chill passive guy
yeah and then they they diagnosed him
with being uh bipolar
manic depressive
so on certain episodes that he would
have
he would be very calm and very like cool
and very like likable and then the other
side was when he would go and kill women
so like this dude that's pretty extreme
a lot like
michael
michael chen michael can't be a murderer
actually because he just seems like one
too much
you should see my mafia games it's like
you know
innocent people don't confess that that
they're mafia
but he's guilty as [ __ ] yeah
you start sweating like crazy you're
such a wild card yeah he is a wild guard
i don't play to win i play to lose
that's why wow that's something ted
bundy said he believes
word for words
what do you think is the fascination
right now with serial killers like it's
always been a thing but now it's like
everyone's [ __ ] into it dude like
look at this [ __ ] like this guy is
talking to this woman
and
he's not being a murderer like we all
expect him to he's being a person very
cool which is super weird logical
sounding yeah is this the witness and we
kind of don't want to believe that
people can be like this we want them to
be like a disney villain yeah
yeah like jafar
that's what they kept saying the
documentary
like they kept saying like oh there's no
way he could have killed all these
people there's no way he's such a night
likeable guy but this is before they
have knowledge of like mental illness i
think someone kill is like they're
unlikable they're so smart
think about how dumb think about how
dumb we all are like i don't like we're
playing mafia and [ __ ] i'm like i don't
know
bart's not asking anything right now
let's just kill this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm the [ __ ] cop guys look what you
guys are and then we're like oh well you
should have defended yourself better
it's like the most absurd [ __ ]
it's just pointing fingers
yeah yeah your jk party have you seen jk
party i want to show you guys
next time so fun oh we love it i'm
[ __ ] really good you are actually you
are pretty good i got lucky i got you
you shouldn't chuck your own dick you're
good thank you thank you but we only
give our defenses in rhymes though yeah
in order to defend yourself that has to
rhyme you have to rhyme or else you're
out yeah damn haiku style too okay good
you said hi could feels rap cultural
appropriation
we could say haiku because joe is
japanese yeah i could say haiku because
my wife is a half
filipino
he just stops because she's a house
that's awesome i can
that's pretty cool
those are some sick perks what kind of
what kind of uh rights do you get with
your significant other
what things can you do
i don't know [ __ ] what do you mean
what rights do you have
privileges do you get i don't just
taiwanese what do you think you get beef
noodle soup all day baby oh just can't
say that it's a country that's all
that is still so weird to me like i
still think about the john cena i think
where he was just so cringe watching him
have to apologize oh man like taiwan
wasn't a country he said it out loud to
the world it just shows you how much
power china really likes china china
control are you scared people like money
so they'll say whatever
he says he probably said something he's
like oh [ __ ] my bank account's gonna be
half of this let us fix it right now
dude they're so legit they they're doing
it right in china yeah like they're
holding everyone by their balls
like the fact that marvel studios with
shanxi and eternals the fact that they
can't release in china because china's
like [ __ ] you guys is crazy today's
video is brought to you by nutrafull um
i think i overdosed on the product and i
wasn't supposed to take this much and uh
i don't think it's a bad thing i think
it worked out great look here we go it
looks strong and healthy i know and you
know what
aside from this though it has great side
effects like uh higher libido it makes
me feel great and vigorous if you know
what i mean
vigorous huh that's good and what's cool
about that is that the neutrophil is
physician formulated and it's completely
drug free did you know that 80
million people in the u.s alone
men and women experience thinning hair
damn that's that's mind-blowing dude
that's like a huge population yeah
because like i think we got about 300
million so like man that's almost a
third dude yeah wow but you know what
people should do is they should take
charge and they should take control by
making sure you can grow thicker fuller
hair baby like you not all of us is
balling like elon musk and can get
[ __ ]
hair magically appearing because he was
like in tesla technology and then he
makes it you know his baldness go away
not all of us are that you know rich but
thankfully there is an easier
alternative and much more affordable
than using tesla technology yeah and
what's cool about nutrafull is that in
clinical studies
72 percent of men and 86 percent of
women in just six months they were able
to improve their coverage like crazy wow
and you can sign up for the subscription
service that you can pause and freeze at
any time and the shipping is free
that's a wonderful deal yeah so if you
want to grow thicker healthier hair and
support this show make sure you go to
nutrafull.com
otr to get 15 bucks off of your first
month's subscription this is their best
offer that's available anywhere and it's
only available for us customers for a
limited time so if you want to grow a
thicker healthier hair make sure you go
there nutrifort.com use the code otr
only for the jk fans thank you very much
that's the reason why huh yeah well how
come they can't release in china i think
there's something i think simon might
have said about like just something
simple which is truthful about his
family like leaving communist china
being hungry for like [ __ ]
you can't play it here and that's the
big money maker eternals chloe zhao the
uh austria award-winning director for
she directed she directed a new marvel
movie she said something about leaving
communist china when she was younger and
china's like they found that one expert
and they're like you can't play a marvel
movie bart's talked about his dad
escaping that's why that's why jake is
playing china dude he doesn't well i've
been to china many times and i really
enjoy going there
oh you're a sellout the way this guy
talks about chengdu people is offensive
is so dope dude taiwan's not a country
[Laughter]
damn that's crazy power right there dude
it's all about money right it's all
about money because if you open your
movie in china you're going to make like
300 mil more you're going to three x
that yeah exactly but when your
country's just controlled by one party
you could plan for like a hundred years
straight yes you have no competition
whereas like here there's so much
infighting everyone's only thinking
about like four-year terms that's why
i'm okay with fascism
[Laughter]
you can say that you shouldn't you
shouldn't say that man only i can say
that he can say that i can't say it
you know but you know what i heard
though like so from my filipino friends
who have property in uh the philippines
okay they're really thankful for duarte
because they're like finally the [ __ ]
man i can own property invest and i feel
safe with my [ __ ] that's not gonna be
like jacked or corrupt or anything from
the mafia yeah they're like they feel
like yeah you can own real estate and
their stability and there's all this
[ __ ] so i was like okay well yeah duarte
is pretty draconian and pretty nuts
but
if there's a positive side where people
feel safe now
i didn't know there's al qaeda in the
philippines yeah there's they have
terrorist groups there yeah it's crazy
it said uh where my family's from mid
and out half a lot of muslims so it's
like everything is catholic and then
really southern region a lot of filipino
muslims no way
have you met a filipino pirate
yeah right like captain putangana crook
i was like i was like what filipino bit
is he gonna do it's all the record
you know you know they have how much
filipino stuff do you know because of
your wife uh like what are like no
because of yeah her wife and her whole
family like like i know like the food's
great i know i've never been what's your
favorite filipino dish oh dude i have to
well it depends i i would say ponce it
was like crazy
it's just interesting how like because
like in jordan george like knowing what
a filipino was and i come here to
california every [ __ ] asians like i
gotta filipino friend like everyone just
grows up with filipinos oh cause you're
in georgia right i was like there's a
hell of filipinos here exactly
hawaii
like i think japanese and filipino are
the highest [ __ ] like minority group
that's a majority group in hawaii my
best friend in fourth grade is filipino
what's his name marquise barretto damn i
brought his cat to class sorry monkeys
were you brian's camp well first of all
why did you bring the camp why did you
stole his yeah so he he uh he lived
right across the street from the school
from our elementary school so my mom
were fourth so i think i was nine okay
so my mom would drop me off at his at
his house in the morning she has to get
to work at like seven
and we would watch tv hang out and then
i'd talk to his four grandmas i live in
there and then we would walk to school
and then one time he showed me his new
baby kitty and i'm like oh man this
guy's so cute i'm like we should bring
him to school he goes nah we can't i'm
like all right so he went upstairs to go
take a shower so i did the logical thing
which is put the cat in my backpack and
then we took this guy hella chinese
we went to school and then he sat in the
uh he sat in the chair behind me and you
know those desks where you put your
books in i was like yo marquise check
this out
and he's like what the [ __ ] you brought
my cat and the cat started meowing and
[ __ ] and the teacher had to call uh
marquise's dad
bro you're wild dude this is this is
what you have to look forward to when
tycho's in fourth grade
people can't dude
you don't know how to have fun if you
bring your cat to school it's gonna be a
party
and he's right he's right he did this
this is marquise
[Laughter]
that's him wait that is that that's one
piece this is where the americas they
got the dopest name though his name was
marquise his brother's name was giovanni
his cousin's name francesca and then uh
francesca's little sister is genevieve
i'm like man philippe those are cool
names filipinos they also got some dumb
ass names like in the philippines like
gilbert i know like like gilbert like uh
manny pacquiao's daughter's name i
believe her legal name is queen
elizabeth queen elizabeth so middle name
i think is elizabeth's first name is
queen it's kind of a bad example because
that name is tight as [ __ ] it's kind of
cool like first name queen
our ambassador manager name's ren raniel
i'm like right now it's a dope name too
i would never admit it during person
that's pretty cool why don't you tell
her that no never i bet every single
filipino family has somebody named j.r
j.r yeah i know like two jr's i could be
a jax i'm junior so sometimes if you're
just already a junior then they'll just
call you jr oh that's why
my father-in-law his name is ben and all
of his brothers are also named ben for
all benjamin's every guy is benjamin
yeah wait are we brothers yeah how do
the parents address them all then
ben three
they have different nicknames so like
he's he's uncle
jiggy for some reason uncle jiggy
because he moves funny i guess i don't
know he's yeah they call him uncle jiggy
uncle jiggy
and then uh there's uncle
i think it's called one butch
oh that's just a lesbian
no i swear this is all true that's kind
of true like their nicknames it's like
you also like repeat a lot like my dad's
also gilbert so they'll call him like
gil yo or like if you like he has
another brother named uh jing they call
him jingjing so they're just repeat
stuff too so what's yours
my name is actually
man when i was growing up as punk boy or
gigi boy
boy so let's say gigi boy i like gigi
they say gg did you
yeah because you're a double g uncle
benny's another one it's weird because
they're all benjamins yeah
gotta figure it out
yeah
bibi
because the nicknames do get kind of
more creative there was a family at our
school they're they're i think three or
four brothers too and they're all yips
all right yep yep yep the last name no
they're first their first names
yeah
they're all yip
dude that's i've only seen that as a
last name it's weird too because your
dad's name is zachary
this is obviously benjamin yeah but yeah
oh
that is crazy they have four kids or
five kids and all the same there yeah i
don't wanna think about it man we fight
too much i hope your next kid is also a
tiger yeah just like [ __ ] your kids
it's gonna be biker dude
like uh i like that wow
steve you're thinking about having kids
eventually right yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah
he's gonna have a bedroom monster i do
have red but i can't say here we go
because i don't want anyone to steal my
name what is it anyone in our friends or
boys
what's that
luna dude it's gonna be great
[Laughter]
you gotta look in the comments you gotta
you don't sleep on communities oh yeah
what's up what's what's up with
no way [ __ ] well thank you very much you
know pleasure check your legend we
bought you a bunch
happy birthday okay wait till i'm a
billionaire
you'll be a billionaire in quantity
but not dollar value definitely no way
definitely you'll probably end up owing
money to like finance or some [ __ ] yeah
exactly i don't know how bitcoin works
dude bro what are you searching right
now huh jiren genevieve barbato
i'm like we're talking i look over it's
just a google it which is all white
women
there's a lot of white ladies named
genevieve she looks like she died though
all right
i was trying damn oh memorial photo for
sure definitely that is a great
depression name huh it sounds like a um
like a medieval name isn't it as well
genevieve yeah like a renaissance name
maybe filipinos like to choose some old
school names huh matty gold they're dope
though i like them marigold you type in
filipino names i'm actually curious sure
it's like the top ten at dole ball
it just it always turns into the food it
just slowly involves the food yeah like
that's a good one ambrosio yeah
i
obviously yeah there's a hitler
yeah
have you guys been to uh tony's like
it's like a filipino barbecue on the
west coast stop looking at me michael
when you ask that what's that venus
i should try it out patrick or um the
editor he turned me onto it and it's
like my favorite place ever yeah let's
check it out tony's and it's um the best
thing in my life
is like a like authentic philippines i i
don't know if it's authentic or not but
i love it and their best thing is like
they're barbecue chicken
it's like tony's beloved it's not
authentic even if you love it that's not
okay what is authentic how do you guys
define a fentanyl frickin impossible
exactly there's like a filipinos like
southern barbecue place
close to the i think 110 or 101. that
one's really good is it authentic it's
not authentic but it's more fusion style
bert's finest right yeah park's finest
but that's really good that's good too
they got like the that's like southern
barbecue but like filipino flavors to me
that's authentic though authentic
because that's specifically like l.a
filipino like how they grew up in the
neighborhoods how they did oh because
the whole thing was like i don't know i
get so annoyed with the authentic stuff
because people are like it's gotta be
authentic dim sum i'm like i don't even
know what that means because it's
different everywhere and it changes
every five ten years anyway it's like
food evolves have you ever been to chef
tony's yeah what's that oh the new dim
sum place that closed down and pasadena
but they reopened it next year and then
they closed it
yeah again though yeah is it good i
heard it's very good but it's like it's
like uh
that's it though i have no idea i think
it is actually tony sounds like a very
cantonese name i like the very simple
idea that you're just in the country and
therefore it's authentic not that
there's bad restaurants in every country
people who suck at cooking in every
country oh no it's from here so
therefore it's authentic also
technically synthetically shitty
[Laughter]
if i ever heard it in my life i've had
some like really bad filipino-made
spaghetti that's not like
very good at all well because you don't
you know what you're eating you guys i
love it oh i love filipino spaghetti
what's in it go
hot dog spaghetti why'd you change your
accent
no i didn't mean to do that at all but
hot dog
is there ketchup in there as well or
banana ketchup banana ketchup oh is that
why it's so sweet
banana ketchup and they put brown sugar
sugary
[Music]
[Music]
you